so we got civil wars part two and holy
shit the the twist of a lifetime oh my
god
tarrlok 2.0 what turns out was not a
good guy that's how I got blow out the
point where this way there we go oh fuck
it there we go okay so alright so on the
one hand who knew on the one hand yes it
was so friggin obvious on the other hand
he wasn't doing anything necessarily to
indicate well no as soon as he brought
in the other people like hey we have to
keep everybody separate we have to I
mean it's like wait a second let's go
back to like episode 1 no no to us it's
obvious if I to everyone else it's sort
of like particularly core you can sort
of understand it but as soon as you
start bringing the soldiers it's like
the second the soldiers and I would sit
like wait a second yeah that this is not
cool and yeah you understand enough some
serve at a crossroads mostly leading
towards yeah come on could you tell
because I don't know if the audience can
tell it's so obvious why have the
characters goes so long through not
knowing you know I thought my episode 2
I mean uh three I mean Howard Hughes
figured it out he said as much in the
episode yeah hey I've been saying it
from the beginning
yeah was he doing remote oh maybe he was
yeah well they if they were after him so
by the way he he's funny favorite hobby
and uh oh now I'm forgetting her name
all I just added the crazy girlfriend
now fiance oh wait what are they Desna
and Eska Desna as you know when I go to
write we think that's it but does he
lose yeah
so it is strange because all these are
size stories you got you got a bowline
you got the you know and obviously his
now fiancee
you got you got Tencent and the stuff
going on with his family that great
scene where he comes across the daughter
and she's making her new family that
scene was one step away removed from
like Bridge to Terabithia crazy like why
she was talking where's she's talking to
the flying melons no it's okay he's nice
it's it's cool it's like scary we ruled
the water nation and nothing crash nice
ass yeah oh it was charming but take it
one step further than it and it's like
be insane um as crazy as it is talking
to baby Buffalo with arrows on there
I'll say asking how the hell do they
tattoo the arrows it's a natural force
it's on the first yes yes no you spray
paint enough I guess so I don't know but
you know you got that story going on you
got the artist formerly known as Howard
Hughes who's hilarious you got all this
stuff going on and then platypus-bear up
this which by the way if you put jazz
rap videos there's a bear it's a
platypus money like it was laughing I'm
just like it's totally a plan why do we
r platypus have to be so funny it's it's
just you want point on everything I'll
blame the Australians um but and you got
all this going on and yeah sort of again
like not that this was a bad Korra
episode like for the character I mean I
mean she didn't do anything very big she
has some nice kick-ass moments she
actually did something in this episode
which is what I've been at least waiting
for yeah and of course the big fight you
know don't do anything rash everywhere
just like what not worse but it was a
cool scene and at the very least I mean
she could okay the one thing I buyer's
me is that she couldn't sense that the
judge was so obviously bought off and
just
Tomomi but was going up yeah it's just
like you know be lenient on them okay
it's like all it takes is the man it's
like I don't like how she one of it's
like you're gonna let him go cuz again
it's like what do you think boy - if she
went up and said okay I think
something's up I think you were bought
off that would make more sense but it's
like come on we were we were joking when
he was explaining the whole thing to her
and we were just like really you
couldn't figure this out it was like
episode 1 material you know and then
what do you mean my uncle's bed really
well then you know and with the father
to us are realizing that it's you know
when he tells her don't do anything rash
it's it's like do they know this
character you know wouldn't it make more
sense if he grabbed rands you know don't
do anything rash and says okay negress
he says no really listen to me don't do
anything you know act like although I
guess he's been away for years I mean
like they haven't seen each other I
guess I kind of makes sense they're
getting a whole yeah I may be bad too I
don't know but I see yeah it's like the
connections with Korra are not like I
said it's not necessarily bad but it's
not the strong as all the other
connections are the ones I really want
to watch the funny thing is I've read
some backlash against her threatening
the judge or you know cephas siccing nag
on the judge the funny thing is that
didn't bother me because I would assume
that she knows now I go well enough that
Naga would never bite down unless she
gave an explicit order so what I felt
more disturbing is the first words out
of her mouth was something to the effect
of if you take his life I take yours
motherfucker
I was like holy shit did she just
threaten a judge in front of like a
hundred people yeah now to be fair
that's more stupid that is I don't think
she would actually yeah I know the guy
but it's like it's just stupid you know
and it's I don't know it's like you see
the cool kick-ass scenes like she goes
in and Navi avatar stay and that's gonna
boost the shits and she did something we
I mean she did some cool stuff the
threatening scene is a cool scene like
it's just more it's like can it be more
I had to laugh because somebody on my
facebook was like oh yeah in this
episode like
or finally does stuff and she takes
action and she finds out that you know
her uncle is bad and she's fighting to
write the Ronson
are you happy Robin dog are you happy
Shane boy go to sneeze I'm like yes I'm
happy but I am a little kind of weirded
out that it only took the threatened
death of her parents for her to finally
wake up and be like oh yeah there's like
things happening and maybe I should be
concerned now yeah I I think my big
problem is I hate doing these G likes
and be like you know my probably Korra
this week but it's kind of true there's
always serve that dumb come on catch on
to it and not see he's the Vil my gets
it I can give a little bit of leeway
because he is very persuasive and even
worse or like well I mean we know he's
the bad guy obviously but at the same
time you can see how she's kind of being
duped it's that she goes up to the judge
and if she could pick up hey something
is up here something is wrong here it
would make sense because anyone could
watch that trial be like whoa wait a
minute this doesn't add up obviously
something's going on but instead you
know she goes against her father's
orders it you know and does the soap
into anything rash yeah no it does she
didn't do anything rash her giant
manbearpig polar dog yeah well it's
under order yeah and no Naga was
concerned did you not listen to her Naga
was upset she's a special dog with me
it's the fact that she didn't pick up on
and was still threatening the judge and
you know change it around Chitra I mean
pretty much acting like a thug I mean
not was very thuggish yeah but wish you
went totally vigilante Batman no no no I
mean it was like some other bit dark now
he can get behind vigilante Batman cool
stuff he was smart yes if she was smart
she was doing for hey what's going up
where hey you know like but she didn't
even know he gave
Meishan by mistake and she's like oh
yeah wait what I'm like you didn't I
mean uh hi knew it all along changed
this sentence I was only following
orders
I said change this at weight what orders
like yeah I mean it's got hmm so she's
still some cool kick-ass scenes but it's
like like you said you've all involved
the character okay to to positives at
least I mean a high five bro
we called it oh yeah so I mean I mean
yeah we called it from the beginning but
here's the thing
at least this whole kind of detour where
it's like yes he's obviously the bad guy
yes yes move it along move along three
episodes I've seen shows where they do
this for a dozen episodes yeah I mean
now we can get to that Carla and I mean
let's be fair I mean Oona looks a little
different tarrlok
that went nearly 12 I mean what was it
eight episodes before finally he was
outed so we went through this Alice even
like that one it's just like note it
like even tense it's like no no you're a
bad guy you want power I just can't get
rid of you yet there wasn't court kind
of blackmailed into that in the first
season like I didn't watch tonight I
don't read that being a big problem is
more that other side me but okay
obviously out it you took like a episode
so I mean to be fair we're like only one
three episodes four if you count the
first as a two-parter is something like
so what is it five four five oh I don't
know it's episode I thought was like
five percent well it doesn't matter I
mean oh whatever
many more coming up yeah it hopefully
we're done with the blatantly obvious
bad guy like I mean it's it's all done
now he's been outed core knows what's
going on and I do to some degree
actually like how una lock is able to
back or not required her to be dumb to
get her there in the first place but I
do like how he's created the perfect
trap he's like go ahead start a war
that's that you know your job is the
avatar than its forfeit it's like you
I've totally backed you into a corner
it's like oh yeah well you need to open
no I don't I was like oh she's really
kind of screwed like so I'll be
interested to see how like it seems like
they wanted together to that point where
she's completely backed into a corner
and I'm totally for that I just wish
they found a way to do it where she
didn't have to be just kind of clueless
yeah I mean but if the audience can fake
I mean I don't even think it's like
grown-ups I mean it's like kids can look
at this guy be ia bad guy bad guy I mean
it's like it there were scooby-doo
villains that were more you know yeah
why make her not catch on to it I don't
know at the very least you to make it
after tarrlok you would have thought bad
cuz they just I've seen it so it's like
at the very least I mean they did make
him kind of charming and everything but
you still know it's a bad guy and make
it a legitimate shock that he's the bad
guy and not so obvious the second I will
say the second thing that I kind of like
its I agree it's been handled a little
kind of yeah but that sounds good but
the second thing I kind of like is it
took me a while to figure designers like
three episodes in but I realize of
course Achilles heel as a person is she
has completely she has no intuitiveness
like zero intuitive abilities and what's
interesting about that is that is the
exact opposite of an egg was I mean he
spent a lot of time not fighting pretty
much he was looking for a way to get out
of fighting at the very end of the city
more escape he was very he was always
escaping and he was always trying to
learn and he was very intuitive he could
read people he was trying to solve
people's problems he was trying to be
the avatar Korra to her credit I don't
think it's a bad idea again I think it
could be executed a little better but
she is a hundred eighty degrees
different she's all action she's all I'm
gonna do something let's do something
I'm gonna kick his ass I'm gonna do this
but when it comes to reading people and
having like an intuitive ability to
sense what's going on she's terrible
you know they've been really really
terrible but you want a good example of
that done right I it I don't know mrs.
change compares her perfect comparison
ah look at Zuko Zuko was always like you
know he was very rash and he wouldn't
rush in and I you know I wrote was there
trying to you know call him down and
take a chance to take a breath that's
that man he was still a fascinating
smart intriguing character you know and
nobody would look at Zuko be like what a
dummy
you know they could see very much why he
has this ambition why he rushes in why
he has this impatience you know but he
has this great skill as well which Cora
does but he's not he's not a doofus and
he's not obviously fooled and I think
they could incorporate something very
similar in Decorah well I'm the problem
is I don't know if it's occurred to you
but what is Cora missing the
intelligence not to beat dude no no no
no think hard about this a backstory
both Aang and Zuko had an actual really
functioning backstory Aang was story guy
yeah yeah sure after he went into the
ocean Zuko hid as his whole backs are
with his father what is core is family
her parents have more of a backstory
right now and she's the nominee this is
the one thing that does kind of bother
me about this season in particular is
season one should function as her
backstory as how she's gotten here and
the one thing I was trying to figure out
what where I was looking for cuz I was
like I don't want to say she's regressed
so I was asking him Facebook ins couple
people came up with a great term for I
was like it's more like stagnation like
we hit a certain point and she's just
stopped and I feel that way like when I
look back on season one which I thought
was an awesome season and season two so
far I think has been fun but when I look
at season 2 him like what did I need to
see in season one yeah that would lead
was there anything I really needed to
see that oh this explains everything
that's going on now I'm not feeling it
yeah yeah she'll all I need season one
to get to she lost her powers hit her
lowest point and immediately got it back
and it's like it's kind of what
right back where yes yeah like right
back where she was right before she lost
her powers yeah so I just I know I just
don't feel like that's my one problem so
far it's like I'm still having trouble
feeling Cara I feel her a little more
here because she did stuff like if we
can joke about it that yeah she's turned
into a thug of it in this event but at
least there's like action and a
character motivation so I'm hopeful that
this is like the start yeah like maybe
they already brought ourselves into a
corner at the end of season one it's
like we got to start a new plan and like
okay maybe now the plot really begins
it's like okay this is gonna be her
character journey her arc yeah you want
necessary thing to I mean I mean that's
what I'm looking forward to I'm actually
more psyched now
yeah cause an area back in there too
yeah so yeah and everything else love it
love that complain about it yeah no and
I know some people have a problem with
Boleyn being too goofy but oh I think
it's all hairiness I do too I really I
don't mind it the only thing that's
bothering me is I actually would like to
see Bolin get Asami like I think those
two actually in their own kind of way I
do Bolin Asami with the you know the
others formerly known as Howard Hughes
like I actually saw a want to know the
business dealings and it looks like
they're still gonna be together which is
fine I mean like they're gonna do have
beyond this adventure now I mean The
Shining twins are fun but if they crack
me up I kick I love them too but I'm
like I don't know how long they're gonna
be able to milk Annette I'm like ok at
some point I think you need to move on a
little so I don't I I could sound ending
though I guess they'll take you for a
little bit I I think there is no fences
would get away from my crazy
ex-girlfriend well why do you think I'd
build this room was bears pooping money
so yeah I everything about the season I
I really enjoy I really love except
Korra and uh yeah it's not like I hate I
don't hate or anything but it's like
yeah just she's so far I I think it's
like ma coalesces is like there's a week
and I've never
there's nothing wrong with mock oh he's
a perfectly fine serviceable character
damn it but when you've got so many
other great characters he's kind of like
yeah he is the one that you can kind of
say is the we chased out of all I think
you're really hit with the bags and this
time it's switched and no and since I
think he here with the bag story I think
that the others had a pass and they had
something to learn from they had a base
to start from and all she has is
disability and living up to that ability
which is a lot of pressure but ain't had
that to and this backstory and Zuko had
this backstory to well in look on I mean
then hold me and I mean let's be honest
here what happened in that part of the
story what was the best part of this
episode when they flashed the picture
that showed Aang and Katara years and
the three kids and it's because you have
that backstory there and that was a
story that did nothing he looks for his
daughter they have a fine tea party
we're still a family yeh but you know
the backstory you're so much more
invested in it and even her parents even
a hint said the backstory thank you as
parents I was more kind of like wow
because I know the father's backstory I
know the uncle's backstory and you know
it may be something out of Thor but you
know I think two brothers who are
jealous and then you know it it works
because of that yeah so in the same
thing with Marco but like pretty much
any of them have I think sort of a
functioning back serene core is the only
one that I'm like sure how much is there
at least I guess maybe bowling and Marco
don't have a huge backstory but those
attached to Cora's know in mock oh they
hinted a backstory and the game a little
bit of one I don't want mine as you know
more of his backstory honestly cuz I
read that the scar so with the scarf
like his dad to him or something like
that so I'm a might know a little bit
yeah there were things so far Cora's big
thing is she couldn't airbend and cuz
she's you know being aggressively dumped
and she's not really learned you know
it's like we thought you learned in the
first season but nope
bill aggressively done so and even if
you want to bet I do because I've I've
talked to some people about this and I'm
like you know if you want to argue that
they're making her impulsive to
differentiate her from egg and that
that's gonna be her thing that she's
just never gonna be intuitive she's
always gonna be action-oriented and we
have to deal with it I'm okay with that
but it does become a test of patience
when you know as an audience members
something that the character doesn't
yeah I mean then it's kind of signal
lighting your time like get on with it
you can relate with the character cuz
we're we're three steps ahead of her so
why should why do we want be with a
character they're three steps behind us
but again in defense three episodes I've
seen this done much worse I'm just
grateful it's over yeah let's now we
gonna do now like I said I get that's
what we thought were a like more of the
spirits more of the spiritual world
let's see let's see her learn about in
this I'll see her go into the spiritual
world did you pick up on the other one
that no you're gonna have to go and talk
to the president because we're gonna
need the United forces help and if you
need the United forces you know what
that means it more of that please yes to
it would definitely that'd be cool well
I hope that I also do that that'd be
great
what it'd be great feels like just part
of the whole sky becomes yeah he had
that little thing at the end it's like
what the gravy's like now like a
permanent during the season during the
fangirl Joy gasm when he came back last
season I thought the internet explode so
yeah hopefully yeah let's see we're
gonna get into the spirit world into
developing you know her you know makin
time psyched now I hopeful I could be
wrong I'm hopeful that like okay now
we've got the plot rolling we we've
turned over a new leaf we're good we're
good to go
bring it on it's gonna be awesome let's
go let's go bye